not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter download the qurani app now and
have a ramadan with allah's book like
you've never had before
[Music]
foreign
today i had a very interesting guest who
actually had a podcast with uh regarding
the whole issue in afghanistan but he
came to london and his final movement to
london inshallah um and yeah he came to
visit us
alhamdulillah and yes how are you how
are you doing right now
it's nice to see you a person we met
before as well we bought me some afghani
clothes
i'll be wearing them and reacting to
them inshallah and he will be wearing
them of course of course inshallah yes
have you seen my kurdish clothes yes
i've seen that oh that's great yes
they're similar no they're completely
different okay yeah yeah but you see
the pakistan goes like a most like a
pakistani because as well so they're
completely different like you know like
a male is a male and a female as a
famous
in that in that sense and that's that's
a topic today so i don't know if you've
seen it but basically there's this new
thing of
superman we know who superman is you
know he's a man he's super and he does
super things as a man um but now but
there's a super woman as well yeah the
super moon as well so that's what i have
a problem with that in the context
obviously they need to dress up in a
hijab of course they can be super woman
but the point is here now we've got a
super bisexual so they put something in
between now yes now they want to
mishmash it uh in that sense now we have
a right to criticize um
in a constructive way um and disagree
with that
and we're not calling for any hate was
an individual etc but i really wanted to
address this issue because
now you have superman who is bisexual
and he is seen
kissing and it reminds me of someone
killing another man this is another man
and someone said i can't remember when
where this was from but there was a
person who's pro lgbqt who's saying that
basically we are coming for your kids
this was a statement he made i remember
where it was from so it's an outright
claim of war yeah we're coming for your
children and that's exactly what they're
doing now we saw it of netflix um there
was this movie of these girls twerking
they're like 12 years old man i'm trying
to say yes the cue decided
that's it yes so for example
how where do you think this is going
because there's a clevis in the quran
where shaytan which is an enemy uh to
all of us um has promised allah that
he's going to misguide us by changing
the creation of allah it specifically
talks about cattle or cutting the ear
but this doesn't just stop there so
are you not concerned like i'm genuinely
concerned because there's an eye on the
quran clearly we do recite in the for
in the prayer as well um
yes that amongst the
and uh
humans yes
it makes you wonder why
they are promoting the corporation this
um lgbtq community
no other ideology been promoted to this
degree yes that right now you're not you
cannot find netflix movie yeah without
having a bisexual or lesbian or gay in
it yes you won't find for example
they're trying to promote this idea some
people need to really reflect why
they're doing it in the first place
why i don't think it's even promote it's
enforcing now like a child who is just
10 or 12
he does not have the right to choose
what time you want to sleep
and he does not have the rights to skip
his schools but he has a complete right
to change his gender yes
so do you think it's normal
this is a clear enforcement of children
the way you said that they're coming for
children of course they're coming yeah
yeah and i don't think that this is in
any shape or form benefiting the future
benefiting humanity
because my only question is if you
genuinely believe that the whole course
most is perfectly designed by the
creator yes then why you can't adjust to
the fact that he can also design a
perfect system for humans as well why do
you have to twist it
you know what's very interesting this
book which i'm reading uh by zeeshan
irreversible damage he recommended it
for me so this is there's a girl called
kiara bell yeah kiera bell it goes to
one of these clinics where she says she
has gender dysphoria and her parents are
not called the president called to say
you know your daughter's going through
like consultation nothing you feel like
that no problem start hormone hormonal
treat treatment straight away
it goes to a stage where she gets her
breasts cut off
and now by the way it has no um
effect on her mood yes he said the
evidence base for the streamer is yet
highly uncertain finally the court noted
the clinic's admission that the young
woman who had begun the process of
hormonal transition has shown no overall
impo improvement in their middle
psychological well-being so she gets her
breast calf she's getting uh
testosterone yeah
and at the end result is i still have
the pressure and i'm still in the same
spot i was with two less breasts now
she sues them
she's taking them to court
after how many years i think it's about
maybe four five years she's in her 20s
now okay so in a nutshell she's saying i
went through a face
how are you just taking my word they're
making me cut my own you may not consult
my parents or my doctor oh i could be
crazy i mean i could be insane for that
moment or maybe i'm drunk yeah i'm
coming whatever it may be we're not
saying every person's insane what we're
saying is it's a big life-altering
decision you know so the point is this
problem sisters and this is where i
don't want to long the video out is that
these are life-altering body you know
amputating decisions you know and to me
it's like a lot of people come and say
why is islam so harsh they have harsh
rules on certain things for example the
freedom freedom of speech you know uh or
certain ideologies what you do in your
private house and regard um in contrary
to what you do in the public because
what we can see today is that those
doors have been left open and any time
you let a human being be free like full
free
we can see the consequences of that um
you know and and there is non muslims
out there who agree with us it's not a
muslim issue or a jewish or a
christianity issue this is an issue
where it's
pertaining to all of us where this has
gone out of control so much that now
superman is bisexual in california there
are there is gender neutral toy section
you know and they are enforcing there
was a uh person is a
i think the psychologist i thought
pediatrician i found if i'm not mistaken
peterson no no cannot join a person he's
a pediatrician
so anyways the thing is he doesn't
experiment so not him but he has one of
these um colleagues uh not calling them
um clients so what they do is they're
like okay look let's not enforce to
their daughter adults let the player
play with cars and toys so they give
their they give the daughter a van a
lorry you have to see like you know be
neutral so one day she comes and knocks
on the door
and and uh she goes into the girl's
room she's young
and she says shh
because why laurie's sleeping
so she started treating laurie like a
dog okay yeah she said he's sleeping
yeah and then one day she saw the lorry
with the little lorry said this is
lori's baby
yeah the point is the kill turned it
into a dole the van the car she turned
into like you know little baby figure
what is the why they're doing it that's
a question like this is not in demand
this is not the necessity yes it's not
needed yes and it's not many people that
it's not like it's like it's not it's
it's
like i said before man it just comes
back to shaytan's promise to allah that
he will misguide us and that is being
implemented to this day because there is
no boundaries do whatever you like like
the the the utilitarian um viewpoint of
the greatest good for the greatest
amount of people as long as you don't
cause harm but what they don't realize
is that individual who's not causing
harm to others is causing harm to
himself and when you have a group of
these individuals yes there's community
even though the concept is don't harm
another do whatever you like but you're
harming yourself and if each individual
harms itself now we have a pandemic of
mental health
it goes on it goes on but that's my last
statement is there anything else you
want to say guys in a nutshell we can
see where it's going and wallahi
we all need to i don't know at this
stage what we can do but you know we
we just ask allah to help us that's all
we can do because it's being promoted
left right and center hope you guys
benefited from this video bro and
sisters till next time inshallah share
this with your friends and family and
family members to insha allah take
precautions in place and educate our
children and educate our kids